how does an actor find the truth within
themselves
i don't know i don't know the answer to
that
i i don't know uh i don't know how one
finds the truth
um within himself really um
well here it is okay
the way i believe
the way you feel in private and this was
talked about in the strasbourg stuff you
know the lee strasberg academy they
teach
you know from the point of view of
yourself right you are the character
essentially
the way you are in your private moments
uh if you're willing to take a risk
and show that in front of people
if you're willing to breathe and say
if i'm doing a scene that requires you
know
you know to if i'm directing an actor
and i and i care
i'm passionate about directing theater
if i'm gonna direct them i would say uh
to
what when you whenever you were in your
most private moment
what did that you had a human experience
you've never shared it with me
i guess good acting is are you willing
to publicly share that
in the high in disguise behind
the playwright's intentions and his
character
so the truth i would say is the
willingness to
show yourself to be what you are
in the truest sense of your own privacy
publicly
you